- My next guest asked me to
help her with her love life
because she's been
dumped, ghosted, haunted..
I don't even know what that means.
And exorcisted, okay we
did make those last 2 up.
But it's my first dating segment,
and I might be a little
too excited about it
'cause we're gonna, we're
gonna make romance guys.
Its gonna happen.
(audience cheers)
lets see if I can help her
please welcome Jennifer Young
(cheering)
all right Jennifer, what's going on?
What's the problem?
- Uh kelly, all those
things you said are right
my dating life sucks
- Hahaha, love you
- Um basically, I keep attracting jerks
and I am, I'm from Mississippi.
I'm a southern belle
I think I'm really cool,
I'm really cute and outgoing
and fun, and like..
- She knows who she is.
- Yeah!
- She's confident, I like it
- And I'm confident.
- You need a man that can handle that.
- Exactly.
- You haven't found that yet
- No, I haven't no
- Alright, what kind of guys do you d,
so like they're, they're all jerks?
- Yeah, like.. well not all
I just think, I've been
single for like 3 years
so its, its, its
- Girl, I was single
for like almost 7 years
(combined laughter)
- I'm like that ain't bad
it's like, if it is (mock cries)
- Uh but, I dated a lot of
guys, I've dated all around
and I just keep, I guess I
keep finding guys that are
physically attractive and really cute and
I get really blindsided by..
- Oh and there's not like
maybe a lot going on up here
- Maybe not right, they
just seem to be jerks
like I really like the
tall, dark, handsome
kind of like Chris Evans, you know
like really hot, all American bomb, juicy,
oooh, um
- I love you, what's happening. I love you
- Yes
- Okay, can y'all related with dating?
Before you were married obviously.
Did you ever have bad..
- Did you call Chris Evans
tall, dark, and handsome?
- I think, okay well
yeah, maybe not dark but
he's pretty, pretty handsome to me so..
- He's like, he's Captain America
he's like the whitest dude
- I know, when you said;
tall, dark, and handsome
I thought you were gonna, I don't know
go anywhere but..
- Chris Evans - Captain America
- Yeah
- Okay, well - But he is super handsome
you're right, he's super
handsome, and I hear very sweet
so that's a good one, but okay
all right, I have a solution for Jennifer
as a coach on The Voice,
I'm used to listening
without seeing the person.
It really does make a difference.
Backstage I have 2 great
guys for Jennifer to meet.
Are you interested in meeting them?
- Oh my god, yes.
- Okay, well you can't see them first.
- Okay
- There's a catch,
you're gonna have to use your ears,
instead of your eyes
and I have something to
help you, you know, do that.
Its really worked well
for me, so take a look.
Here we go.
(guitar music)
Here comes my chair
- Oh yeah (audience cheering)
- Okay well, don't break my chair
- Is that the real The Voice chair?
- Its my chair.
That's my real chair
- This is crazy
- No, that is really my chair and I,
I asked. And uh we kind
of hit a bump on the way
don't ruin my chair boys.
We're calling this, blind dating.
All right, are you ready Jennifer?
- I'm ready!
- You're ready, I'm ready
all right, lets meet the guys.
- Oh my god
- All right,
go ahead and introduce yourselves.
- Hey everyone, my names Adam.
I'm from Montclair New Jersey,
I'm an award winning
filmmaker and a copy writer
something really cool about that,
I actually got to work for
the LA Rams last year and
got to take my entire
family to the Super Bowl
- Wow!!
- All right - Okay
- Hi, Jennifer. My name is Rian, I'm 28.
I'm originally from Phoenix Arizona.
And I am a freelance writer by day,
and a comedian by night.
And a little thing about me is,
I'm kind of an extroverted introvert or an
introverted extrovert.
Um, I love going out with my buddies and
having a great time and getting crazy.
And then you can find me on the weekends,
sometimes just cooped up
watching reruns of Datelines so..
- Dateline, oh my god
its so dark but its good.
Um, okay well here's how this works
Adam and Rian will take turns talking,
just like the voice. If Jennifer
hears something she likes
she'll hit the button, the chair will turn
and that will be the man she chooses.
But Jennifer, you can hit
the button at any time
but I strongly recommend patience
and like really listening
so, don't get too excited
like I do at The Voice.
And just hit it right off the bat.
Okay, any last advice you two?
- Ugh, go with your
heart, go with your gut
and ask which um, which host
from Dateline is his favorite
'cause that's important.
(combined laughter)
- All right, lets get started.
Bachelor # 1: what is your
idea of a perfect date?
- My idea of a perfect date;
is definitely something
really adventurous.
I'd probably pick you up on my motorcycle
- Ooh - Oh
- And we'd avoid, like
the boring like 1 on 1
kind of like, over commitment dinner
and maybe like just take
a ride, maybe catch a game
and then maybe ride up the
PCH and catch the sunset,
just you and me.
- Dang, all right. All right.
All right Rian, what's your
idea of a perfect date?
- I like that
- My idea of a perfect
date uh actually involves
another woman. Uh, my dog.
- What? - Oh
- Ohh
- Yeah, I uh, I've had this
girl. Her name is Casey,
I've had her for 11 years,
we've been the best buddies
uh we moved out to LA together
and so uh my idea of a
perfect date, uh date
we'd go up, there's this
night market up from my house
they do it once a week, we take the dog
they got food, they got live music,
its a pretty view of LA.
- Ohh
- We'd walk around,
maybe get to know each other a little bit
and see where it goes.
- Awesome!
- Okay
- Chance, what do you think,
Chance, did you think
he meant another woman
like coming on the date?
'cause I did, I, did y'all think that?
- I was like
- I was like, okay, we're
getting straight to it.
- This is going straight
to your deepest desires.
- But I love a dog, I love a dog
- Yeah man
- You like those dates? They sound good?
- Just I, I, I like I think both of them
are showing strong signs of
being your possible future
husband, uh this is a
full blown commitment
that you're making.
Just by even listening to them talk.
Id be very skeptical
of uh Mystery man # 2,
cause he's changed his
accent at least 3 times since
he first..
So, he could be anybody
- Well but he's, but he's a comedian
so you've gotta kind of keep,
so might keep you laughing
I don't know
lets take it up a notch though,
the best way to know someone
is through the magic of song.
Um, I asked Rian and Adam
to write their own personal
love ballet.
- Ooh - We did not help them at all
Jennifer, hit the button
when you've made a decision
but hey, take your time okay
guys, take it away
- Thanks kelly, hey Chance, Jillian
this all about Jen right, Jennifer
all right, here we go
uh,
kelly asked me, to write you a song
she said to keep it on the
30 but that's not very long
but while I got your attention,
girl I'd like to say
there's a reason we're
both on Kelly's show today.
- Oh wow!
That was beautiful, how's that?
- Thank you, thank you
- I'm gonna it down for
you guys, just a little bit
- All right
- Maybe slow it down,
- Slow it down, all right
- Yeah, I gotta go slow
if you find the truth,
somewhere in your heart
you may discover a place
where love can start
(laughter)
- That was pretty good,
that was pretty good
why don't we get this crowd, everyone clap
yeah, lets go
that's my guy, that's my guy
hold on, here we go
I was told to look for love
in obvious places,
look around this room,
all these beautiful faces
while I haven't seen yours
and you haven't seen mine
you and I both know
its just a matter of time
- Nice
back down here for you guys a little bit
some call me a romantic.
The same crowded rooms
full of the same crowded stares
how empty it could feel,
knowing no one else quite compares
- Lets go, because I know its tough
and its hard to find trust
and you wanna find love
- Yeaaahh
- You gotta see my body
(cheering)
- Oh my god
- Thanks man
- That was amazing
- Nice to meet you
- That was amaze, okay you chose Adam
come here, lets meet each other.
All right, that was pretty good.
That was, you, you
brought the energy my man
I love you.
Has anyone ever ever
compared you to Elon Musk?
Like, like you could be related,
- Yes, yes I get that all the time.
- Like when you came out, I was like,
like a distant cousin. Its really weird.
Its awesome.
- I get that all the time,
yeah I like on the weekly
- All right, I like your motorcycles,
is that where he won you over?
- I like the idea, forsure
- Well, I'll just let you
know. I also have a car so
if you're not comfortable with that,
we can take the car.
- Well, big thanks to Rian.
Thank you so much Rian!!!